with all this talk about deadpool 3 and
then of course you know the mandalorian
having boba fett
in it feel like it's finally time after
four years that we do a reaction
to epic rap battles of history's
deadpool versus boba fett
never seen this one there's so many
great epic rap battles i haven't seen
and for some reason i've chosen this
year in particular to start playing
catch up on it let's see what's going on
hashtag save daredevil just throwing
that out there
[Music]
um
[Music]
huh
[Music]
it's good it's good
deadpool
[Music]
[Music]
oh cool cool
[Music]
[Music]
oh
ah
oh damn dude that was great that was so
cool
that was so cool that was a solid battle
oh ooh boys deadpool that was a great
one
punch robert oh oh
yeah that was fantastic that was
fantastic
yeah that was an epic rap battle
i don't know who to choose is the winner
oh that's a toughy
because like i mean deadpool had so many
fun awesome zingers but then when boba
fett came in he was just like
it was super cold yeah it's like boba
fett had it for me on just like the
savagery side but then deadpool was just
so
perfectly deadpool uh it's kind of
it's a tough toss-up is it that that
early line that they had
uh that deadpool said i felt like a
character that i barely know anything
about and dissing him about the original
trilogy i feel like you know for a long
time a lot of star wars fans have really
gotten to know boba fett
and his backstory and then even now in
the mandalorian that it'll be
appearing more we'll even know more
about him and more than just people who
read the books or saw some clone wars
they'll know
more about boba fett now so i thought
those disc lines at the beginning i'm
like yeah a few years ago
rock solid once we all know about boba
fett
we can't have that same kind of disc
that same kind of complaint you know
when that flow change up to i think that
that might be the thing that edges me
closer to calling it for boba just
because that flow change at the end is
actually
pretty soon like i got a hats off to is
like
i always wonder if it's the same writer
for all of these or if it's a few people
because these are bars man like they're
great
on the referential end but the rhymes
are good like
the flows are hot i don't know if i
missed it but were there any lines that
reference origins will bring because you
got a lot of disc lines uh
from both angles here riffing on their
most popular stuff disintegration
deadpool being played by ryan reynolds
the cable basic line was so
rock solid you know good to be dead
so many of these lines were so wicked
couldn't tell if i could catch any of
those x-men origins wolverine lines if
they had any there because i thought
they would probably do something like
that but one thing that always impresses
me with epic rap battles too is the
visual effects
and their change and production design
throughout each one of these music
videos you know you got
so many different outfits with deadpool
even you get the comic book panel
you get others to get the star wars
setting you get the ship and then you
get other star wars characters in the
background
ah man i'm so envious of this i can't
tell who won
i can't eat weird because at the outset
of the video i was like this is a weird
mashup of characters who i never
expected or thought should go
head-to-head but then when they do
it's it's so perfect i feel like it
would be
if you were to tell me this match was
happening i would instantly assume it's
deadpool
exactly who's going to win and then i
was really surprised by the bars the
mandalorian brought because right
they used he used the insult he kind of
like eminem eight miled him in the way
because there's a lot going against boba
fett you know like deadpool is saying
talking about how the most over
glorified character
the uh he barely has any lines in the
trilogy
he one of them was ah and i love that
comeback too then about how deadpool is
just a bunch of other characters powers
yeah like a ripoff of death strokes it's
like spider-man's eyes you know you're
just saying
healing powers so but my point is though
is there is so much more working against
boba fett here and
what he managed to do was use like yeah
i don't even need much i don't need as
much as you do
and yet i'm still super famous and super
loved i'm like damn that's you know it's
hard to argue with you know showed up
less
yeah he showed up became iconic he
doesn't have to say much or
do much that's just how much essence
this guy apparently has and
so i would edge it out to boba fett just
because of how within the riding of this
epic rap battle he managed to make it
work for him like because he started off
with deadpool saying
you're the most famous character i know
nothing about it yeah
i love that because that was kind of the
view that i shared
towards boba fett for such a long time
man you're such an order of glorified
character but then you know after
getting more knowledge on star wars like
actually there's a big
story to this guy you just read to this
guy you know and so
many years ago i had that interpretation
of him and as i think a lot of people
and probably a lot of people still do
right but utilizing that he didn't have
to go into like a bunch of star wars
canon
from like legends or comics or anything
like that he still worked off of the
movies alone so the fact that he
he worked with the with the few he had
and still managed to make it
really impactful gotta educate the boba
fett yeah that underdog entered
that it's like deadpool did exactly what
i was hoping for and was great but yeah
boba fett had that underdog
edge yes whereas like damn all right
guys well
epic rap battles of history recommend
some other ones to go check out but this
was
it's pretty rock solid not gonna lie i
love the hell out of this one subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever we got a new youtube video up
hit that like button if you enjoyed our
vid
last but not least let's do a
gotta shouts out anissa oliva we missed
her shout out last
month sorry apologies but yesterday i
actually hopped on a spontaneous call
with her
she's a dear friend of ours and then i
hopped on a spontaneous call with her we
ended up talking for like 40 minutes so
anissa it's great catching up with you i
just want to
reiterate a few things we've talked
about i think you're hilarious
relatable you got all the right kind of
geeky
cuteness about you i think you're a
total catch and i can keep going on and
on you're very
caring absolutely pathetic you're
sympathetic
you're intellectual intellectual you
care for
others you give i'm just repeating some
stuff i said i mean the only thing you
added on was the generous part but
i mean you're generous you are uh
gas stations at some point and then you
know we will uh
commune over uh you know cheap snacks
we'll have like a gas station
date we'll buy some cheap danishes and
some you know coffee drinks
and then you know we'll uh set up a
little banquet table on the bathroom
figure it out from there this is the guy
who you're attracted that's right that's
right
i'm just enhancing that right now by
elaborating on this situation we'll have
napkins made of the toilet paper
it's gonna be the best we'll carve a
hole
[Music]